you how well they do crafting the lines
yeah how hard it is to get an
edge uh they they do an excellent job of
of picking that
that spot where um you're gonna have
really a coin flip proposition yeah
exactly how anybody
consistently stays above fifty percent
yeah
those damn sneaky casinos they found a
way to make some money didn't they yes
but it is it's
unreal and i i only gambled a little
once in my whole life i think i've told
you right after i got done with my
career
i had a friend who would ask me a little
bit
and it wasn't even my money he was
giving me a percentage of his winnings
and i was nervous so i just can't
imagine being one of those guys that you
know puts real money on a weekly basis
on it hey people do it people enjoy it
it adds to the
yeah the overall experience for me i i
maybe the fact that we do the picks this
way is our little
enhancement and and really i
i would be so much more upset over
losing five bucks
than i would be over winning 50 so it's
just not worth it to me all right
uh this game i would not bet on this is
one of those chris i would not bet we're
only making the pick i'm only making the
pick because i have to i have no idea
what the hell is going to happen in this
one i really don't that's my disclaimer
and my reasoning for this is very simple
i picked the buccaneers to win the super
bowl before the season
i have tried to come up with an argument
to abandon it because like oh well i
picked them to beat the patriots not the
chiefs if it would have been the chiefs
i would have picked the teams to win
i'm not going to play that game yeah 30
to 27.
it's going to take a couple of big plays
by the buccaneers defense the offense is
going to have to click
and uh good luck holding the chiefs
under 30 points but if they can do it
the bucks can win 30 to 27. that's i've
always liked that squishy
there's just something about that score
it's just enough points right
it's not too many points it's not too
low scoring of a game so that's what i
like yeah i
i hear you i mean i feel like you know
if it's a close game it'll be right
there in that
range definitely you know what i think
is funny
all right so i know you're picking the
bucks but
just your overall tone and things like
that
like you you think the chiefs are gonna
win though like i i respect it i know
that you're going down with your team
that you picked
but i feel like and your spaghetti and
meatballs and
you know some garlic and onions in there
too that it's really going
i think the chiefs are gonna win but
we're just gonna go with the bucks cause
i did it
the only thing that keeps me from
flipping
is the tom brady factor and it was the
tom brady factor that caused me to think
they would get there and beat the
patriots right
and i just feel like the taunt the tom
brady factor is too strong and i know
that you i don't want to trigger you
again with only a few minutes left in
the show because we don't have enough
time for you to completely get it out of
your system
but i feel like the broader tom brady
factor is what carries this team over
the top yeah i hear you i
there's certainly that factor buccaneers
are definitely going to feel more
confident walking into the super bowl
knowing who their quarterback is
uh there's no doubt about that so
i like you i picked the chiefs to go to
the super bowl and play the seattle
seahawks so i was wrong in that aspect
but i did pick the the chiefs to win the
super bowl
in fact i wish we still had that clip
when rodney and coach dungey were
getting on me about
you know picking oh how could you pick
them or do you think
and i'm taking the i'm taking them
against the field this year i'm not
backing down from that
i think this is it i think we see the
chiefs play their best game of the
football season this year
this this week in this game like you've
talked about
full attention bucks brady oh we're
at their home stadium i think you're
going to see the chiefs play the best
game they played all year i'm going
38-20
chiefs win this football game 38-20 wow
wow that's board that's blowout i know
let's blow out 18 points
that's blowout yeah um now that the
chiefs will be
if they win the first team to win
back-to-back super bowls since brady and
the patriots in 38 and 39.
if brady wins he will be 2-0
in keeping teams from repeating because
he kept the seahawks from repeating
they won 48 then they lost 49 to the
patriots and
he would then stop the the chiefs from
from winning two in a row
if the chiefs win this one our storyline
for all off season can they make it can
they be the first ones to do three we
talked to emmitt smith about that
yesterday
why didn't the cowboys win three in a
row well jimmy johnson and jerry jones
could no longer coexist and it was barry
switzer that's why they didn't win three
if everything stays in place and it is
by all appearances some people think
that andy reid's going to retire
and hand the whistle to eric piano oh
why why why
you built the house exactly puts it on
the couch he's been waiting his whole
life to get this damn team he's not
giving up on it now he's going i finally
got it here we go
yeah there's no way i mean you you got
to capitalize on this
um this is going to be awesome i'm i'm
really excited for the super bowl of
course as you are
you know what you know what's crazy mike
i know we have the weekend at halftime
which i'm i'm a very big fan of the
weekend so i'm excited to see that
i don't think i know who's singing the
national anthem
i i think you don't know either saw it
but it was one of those
i'm not sure who that is i i you get to
a certain age where
yeah you're not cool anymore all of them
the
national anthem i i didn't even matt
casey just said who it was and it didn't
even
jasmine sullivan and eric church so now
i'm aware and i'll forget by this
afternoon
one last one for you football historian
who's the team that won two in a row
with two different coaches
two in a row with two different coaches
whoa yeah you got me here hold on a
second
hold on oh the 49ers
yes yes hey i thought of that
i thought of that because um i remember
that there was that sense will bill
walsh retire and it was stunning when he
did
so you know andy reid's not walking away
that would even be more stunning
hey what was the score of super bowl
nine at halftime you know that viking
super bowl
two nothing oh two nothing you guys lost
that one huh
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports